hier soir j'ai accepté la démission de
john wilson ribaute
à mon avis c'est une véritable bombe
cette démission la entre autres parce
qu'il s'agit de john philpot et là il
était pris dans ce scandale des sennecé
lavalin c'est toute sa stratégie que
justin trudeau doit repenser le nouveau
chef du bloc québécois est avec nous ma
plus grande satisfaction c'est qu'il n'y
a plus personne qui puisse sérieusement
dire que le bloc québécois est un parti
moribond et divisé il ne l'est plus tous
les clients touchés devraient avoir reçu
une lettre de desjardins
d'ici une dizaine de jours l'employé
soupçonné d'être au coeur du vol de
données n'a toujours pas été accusée
elle somme le gouvernement à faire la
lumière sur la mort de sa petite fille
qui a été selon elle
martyrisé battus attachés et privés de
nourriture
la cascade d'annulations a commencé
aussitôt après l annonce de la décision
d'ottawa de clouer les boeing 737 max au
sol et de les bannir de l'espace aérien
canadien
le nombre de feux a augmenté de 84% par
rapport à l'année dernière
le pire des scénarios se dessinent au
sud est de l'australie
bonjour rien
c'est un joyeux où c'est vraiment un
église magnifique fait d'être en plein
centre de paris au monument d'un ex cram
valeur symbolique pour la france après
quatre ans de travaux dont six mois de
retard
inauguration en grande pompe du pont le
plus large du canada celui qui sera
aussi le plus achalandé au pays il y
avait longtemps qu'un canadien n'avait
pas flotter dans l'espace 12 ans pour
être exact et david saint-jacques
n'allait pas rater sa chance
[Musique]
les probabilités sont du côté des
rappeuses
dekel championne
[Applaudissements]
elle l'a fait et elle a fait avec
panache contre la plus grande joueuse de
l'histoire
elle vise maintenant le premier rang
mondial
elles peuvent amorcer l'année aux 150
12e échelon merci beaucoup pour ce
soutien m
[Applaudissements]